hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
big businesses have always played a part
in the history of a country car brands
like Volkswagen and Mercedes helped
shape 20th century Germany for the
McDonnells were a big part of the
American Dream and much later Apple and
Facebook now play a huge role in society
but none of these companies compared to
the influence that one conglomerate has
had on its home nation today we're going
to look at how our alliance has
overtaken India they have a huge role in
oil mobile communication media textile
retail and more in India reliance can be
the clothes on your back the oil in your
car the mobile networking use the TV
watch and the food you buy in addition
to all of this the company has started a
digital revolution in the country and
are directly responsible for the rise of
t-series the rapidly growing Indian
YouTube channel that's set to overtake
PewDiePie for the number one spot we'll
also see when Reliance's founder Dhiru
Byam Barney died his two sons took
sibling rivalry to a whole new level so
this video has been requested for over
three years and I think it's about time
we took a look at reliant the business
all starts in the 1960s in the textile
trade dhirubhai ambani moved to Yemen
from India as a young man to look for
work after a few years pumping petrol
for an oil company he moved back to
Mumbai and hope to use a few connections
in Yemen to create an import/export
business the aim was to bring polyester
into India and sense biases to Yemen
however his business partner who was
also his second cousin had a very
different approach embody was a natural
risk-taker unlike his cousin so
eventually the pair went their separate
ways an embody founded Reliance textile
industries in 1966
the business really took off with the
creation of the Vemma brand with this
Reliance textiles will no longer just a
material supplier having their own line
of clothing made all the difference
at first I'm body got his clothing into
the stores by producing it as cheap as
possible but once the voom or bran was
up and running he began a franchise
model of his eye and the Vimal stores
began to spread an advertising campaign
in the late 1970s was the establishment
of the only vinnil brand this brand
became synonymous with young fashion for
both men and women for decades to come
embody was ready to put the company on
the public stock exchange with their
initial public offering however he took
an interesting and new route at the time
stocks and shares were far removed from
the average person and body wanted to
change this so he got the public excited
for the company's IPO and put up about
2.8 million shares the public took
notice and the IPO was extremely
successful in India this is known as the
start of the equity cult where the
general public became far more engaged
in the stock market even today Reliance
has millions of shareholders on the back
of the IPO and the wildly success of the
only formal clothing brand Reliance
continued to grow and then diversified
in 1986 Reliance Capital was established
this subsidiary offers financial
services such as loans stock broking and
n insurance Reliance Capital is
currently one of the largest financial
companies in India continuing on
Reliance would merge with another
textile business at the end of the 1980s
and bought their way into the
petrochemical industry this was a way to
expand in the polymers that they were
already producing but soon the company
had their eyes set on the oil fields
themselves they quickly grew into
India's largest petroleum company at the
end of the 1990s they built a refinery
in Jamnagar it is still the largest oil
refinery in the world it doesn't stop
there though Reliance Infrastructure has
been providing power construction and
defense since 2002 Reliance Defense
build ships has projects and offshore
engineering and although politically
controversial in 2018 partnered with the
French government to produce 36 Raffaele
plans for India and then was reliance
retail which has 45 subsidiaries
including mobile phones jewelry
electronics apparel and groceries more
on all of that later but I think one of
the strangest ventures of Reliance to
Israeli cord this is the storage of AM
biblical cord blood I have to say it's
an amazingly diverse business so far the
drama was soon to follow
in 2002 Reliance's original founder to
rebuy and body died but the thing was he
never wrote a will before he passed away
so his eldest son Mukesh was put in
charge as chairman and managing director
while his younger brother Anil became
vice chairman just like to Roubaix when
he was selling textiles in the early
days with his cousin the two heirs to
the reliance company had very different
approaches and disagreements about the
direction of the company the dispute
spilled out into the public in late 2004
and in something almost never seen
before in corporate history their mother
had to step in to settle the dispute her
idea was to split the businesses the
following year to put it simply the
older brother Mukesh got the oil and gas
business under the name Reliance
Industries and Anil took the
telecommunications finance and
infrastructure part under the name
reliance group it was highly unusual and
more of a family arrangement than a
traditional business deal but the
conflicts continued after the split Anil
was expecting Mukesh to sell him gas at
a lower rate to use for his power plants
but the deal was vetoed by the
government and Anil suspected that his
brother had talked them into it at the
same time and Hill was also failing in
his telecommunications business the
fight became such a matter of public
interest that the Indian Minister of
Finance requested that they settle this
dispute it was the case that the company
was so huge that these arguments were
harming the Indian finance market what a
situation so how did it all work out as
the family feud continued or has it
settled down after 13 years
well today it's pretty clear that Mukesh
has emerged as the victor Anil was
forced to sell Reliance Communications
to his brother about a year ago to avoid
insolvency so the total score is this a
Nils reliance group market cap stands at
13.8 billion dollars while Mukesh's
Reliance Industries total assets are
valued at 130 billion for comparison
Tata Group another huge Indian
conglomerate which have done a video on
is currently worth about 126 billion
u.s. dollars so let's leave the brothers
to squabble for now and look at how
important reliance is for India right
now they have the largest market cap in
India as well as the largest private
contributor to GDP they also have the
world's largest data network and are
still the biggest polyester producer
globally so I guess some of their
original businesses are still going
so as mentioned earlier reliance retail
has 45 divisions
some including reliance fresh which has
fresh produce like fruits and vegetables
and also online groceries and reliance
smart which has apparel footwear as well
as food reliance digital is a consumer
electronics branch that has over 650
retail stores reliance ly F which i
think is shortened for life is a 4g
mobile phone manufacturer established in
2015 reliance retail also does travel
services energy entertainment and
leisure health and well-being products
as well as educational products and
services they have a total of over 3,800
stores which combined cover an area of
over seventeen point seven million
square feet across seven hundred and
fifty cities reliance retail brings in
an annual revenue of over ten billion US
dollars geo is a mobile network
subsidiary of Reliance just one month
after their official launch on the 5th
of September 2016
they had already acquired 16 million
subscribers this is the fastest adoption
of any mobile network operator anywhere
in the world
it took them 83 days to get 50 million
subscribers and by February 2017 they
had over a hundred million people
subscribed to their network so what did
all of these new people coming online
decide to do watch T series on YouTube
of course T series is kind of like an
indian vivo with music videos featuring
bollywood stars essentially as alluded
to at the beginning of this video
Reliance gia cost massive growth in that
channel disrupting the traditional
YouTube order and a set to dethrone
PewDiePie for the number one spot the
geostrategy was essentially this give
away the data for free for three months
and then charge over 30 times cheaper
than the competition this absolute price
slashing technique quickly brought 4g
into every indian home and
single-handedly changed the data
consumption habits of an entire country
combined with cheap reliance mobile
phones now even those in rural areas all
those of modest means like farmers
students and entrepreneurs can finally
have the tools they need to participate
in the modern
economy some analysts suspect that
reliance geo alone could boost the
Indian economy by over five percent in
2018 reliance jail is ranked as the
number one firm to change the world by
Fortune magazine Reliance also owns the
largest TV network in India network 18
which includes an Indian version of CNBC
some commentators speculate that this is
to control the news and public opinion
about the company within the country the
company also offers 500 free-to-air
channels under its reliance big TV
subsidiary okay so almost at the end of
the video but before we end let's check
out three facts about Reliance number
three Reliance Industries has Asia's
largest mango orchard its aim is to
control the pollution caused by the
reliance refinery there's over 100,000
mango trees covering 600 acres of land
with 127 varieties of mangoes number 2
the reliance foundation dura lions
foundation was set up in the year 2000
and supplies funds for education health
care and has the goal of ending poverty
number one in contrast to the last fact
Mukesh embody the winner of the feud
between the two brothers and the one
that owns Reliance Industries is now
worth forty four billion dollars he owns
a twenty seven storey house to
accommodate his family of five there's a
staff of 600 workers he maintained it
24/7 it is the world's most expensive
private residence valued at over 1.3
billion dollars it has ten elevators
parking space for one hundred and sixty
eight cars three helipads and an
artificial snow room and of course
countless other features
so that is the story of Reliance
including Reliance group and Reliance
Industries and all of the widespread
subsidiaries it is amazing to think that
reliance was started just by one man who
worked at a petrol station in Yemen
before selling textiles beginning on a
bicycle in India another fun fact when
it all began he only had three hundred
US dollars to start with now they're one
of the most widespread companies in
existence I guess it just goes to show
that you really can't predict where life
will take you you could start with
nothing and literally build an empire if
you're watching this video from India
and you want to see the story behind an
equally big company you can check out my
video on Tata
anyway thanks for watching this has been
- go go you've been watching cold fusion
if you're new here and you've just
stumbled across this channel feel free
to subscribe and I'll see you again soon
for the next video cheers guys have a
good one
[Music]
you